Animal Planet's call of the wildman'
followed the mostly toothless bowie
knife toting turtleman Ernie brown Jr
around the backwoods of Kentucky as he
responded to calls from people needing
help with dangerous pests his unique
style of catching dangerous prey usually
with his bare hands quickly grew a rabid
fan base but the show abruptly stopped
after its fourth season so what happened
this is the untold truth of the
turtleman hungry for turtles Ernie
turtleman Brown juniors hardscrabble
life is all he's ever known according to
an interview with Channel Guide magazine
Brown told the publication that he got
his nickname at the age of seven saying
we ran out of food one day and my uncle
came over and took me and my dad through
these old farm ponds and he goes I'll
show you how to get some meat on the
table
so he went out in that pond and turtles
started bubbling up shredders got
nothing on this guy nothing but the
tooth aside from his giant knife and
Wildman Yelp the turtleman is also known
for his dental deficiencies most people
start correcting their oral hygiene the
second they make any TV money but not
turtleman speaking with Syracuse calm
turtleman laid out the three incidents
that left him with just seven teeth
saying the first one a guy swung a
chainsaw around and hit me in the face
while we were clearing some brush that
took 189 stitches to sew me back up next
turtleman lost a few more teeth in a car
accident when he tried to quote Dukes of
Hazzard it over a ditch to avoid a
tractor and the third attack on his
choppers he was whacked by a piece of
metal during a roofing job on top of
being a crazy person who grabs wild
animals with his bare hands this guy is
also apparently a walking installment at
the final destination movie franchise in
addition at those injuries he's been
bitten at least 33 times by Turtles at
least once he nearly bled to death after
being bitten on the wrist in a separate
attack a turtle got a mouthful of Ernie
brown Jr 'he's little turtle man animal
abuse after a seven-month investigation
into call of the wildman' mother jones
revealed not only the shady staging of
the rescues on the show but also some
serious allegation
of animal abuse and neglect citing
multiple examples of animal
mismanagement Mother Jones suggests the
production team was complicit in
illegally drugging animals and failing
to properly document wildlife activities
for Kentucky officials in one incident
the crews had dated a zebra which was
procured from a local drive-through
animal Safari which turtleman then
caught in another turtleman cleared bats
from an area that were intentionally
placed there his activities resulted in
the death of one bat and possibly
violated local laws that prevents
bringing a bat to a new location for
entertainment purposes alone which is a
very weird law to have to specify but
hey things get weird when you're bored
after the initial Mother Jones expose
which was published between seasons
three and four of the show call of the
wildman' saw a 43 percent drop in
ratings
although there was never an official
cancellation announcement from Animal
Planet the turtleman never returned
after that dismal fourth season not so
live action despite well-documented
instances of faking genuine animal
captures turtleman insists that he's the
real deal
telling Channel Guide magazine people
have been calling me fake and there
ain't no fake go ahead and try it we're
doing it live action we're there do it
our thing I'm catching animals that's
the way it is
but while the turtleman may be endearing
ly genuine his TV show was not Animal
Planet is remarkably open about this
fact Animal Planet's senior VP of
communications patricia cal apollo
addressed an episode in which quote a
poisonous non-native snake was released
into a city swimming pool without proper
authorization by shifting blame to the
show's producers saying we're clear we
do dramatizations so for us that wasn't
news or controversial sharp
entertainment did bring in snakes there
are times for a storyline we need a
particular animal and we'll work with a
licensor to find the particular animal a
show producer who spoke to mother jones
confirmed the trickery it was part of my
job to call around people to trap
animals at the direction of sharp it's
100% fake lost license
one thing about the turtleman was
definitely real for a time Ernie brown
Jr was a licensed nuisance wildlife
control officer in the Commonwealth of
Kentucky that is until he stepped out of
bounds on TV
in 2013 turtleman was hit with a
violation of his NW Co license after an
episode in which he wrangled a deer out
of his store in exchange for an
authentic suit of armor
one problem deer did not fall under his
jurisdiction as a nuisance officer so
the Commonwealth of Kentucky issued him
a friendly reminder that if he was ever
shown to mess with elk deer wild turkey
or bear again he could lose his license
for three years and possibly receive a
criminal citation
shortly after inconsistencies were found
in turtle man's in W Co paperwork and
several agencies including the USDA and
the Humane Society called for the
cancellation of the show the Kentucky
Department of Fish and Wildlife also
confirmed a Mother Jones that turtleman
was no longer licensed as a nuisance
officer and though they wouldn't say why
the answer is pretty obvious
turtleman strong along with country
artist Steve Oliver turtleman is in the
process of putting together a series of
albums that will tell the story of his
life true to his word he recently
dropped his first music video
turtleman strong it's an ambitious
undertaking for the turtleman to say the
least
he had Oliver have written 90 songs that
they plan on turning into three albums
y'all ain't seen nothing yet turtleman
is coming back 2017 turtleman strong and
with the recent appearance of
turtleman's own official YouTube channel
could this be the resurgence of the
turtleman we've all been waiting for you
subscribe to the channel you'll never
miss any live action thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
you